en el hospital número 3 de crumb atroz
ahora sólo hay una especialidad médica
trauma los únicos pacientes que siguen
aquí son los que aún no están los
suficientes estables como para
trasladarse al oeste hacia la zona de
seguridad como jacob herido por la
metralla en un bombardeo ruso
mi mujer ha muerto mi hijo está en el
territorio ocupado de cree mina no sé
qué pasará después
no
muchos médicos se han marchado y
voluntarios de otros lugares de ucrania
lo sustituyen a corto plazo suelen ser
especialistas en heridas en la cabeza
con las explosiones de los restos del
proyectil vienen de arriba y si los
soldados militares tienen casco entonces
de alguna manera los protege pero los
civiles tienen muy pocas posibilidades
a pesar del peligro los civiles siguen
apuntando sea la defensa territorial de
ucrania y saber cómo tratar las heridas
del campo de batalla es una de las
partes más importantes en su formación
si la heridas en el brazo no puedes
saber exactamente dónde estás así que
tienes que poner el término que te lo
más alto posible del brazo y omnium
todos estos voluntarios dicen estar
listos para cumplir con su deber en el
frente por cornetas transmisión me
importa mi ciudad esta es mi patria no
quiero que los separatistas estén aquí
entramos juro
otros optan por ayudar en la situación
humanitaria como natalia que coordina
tanto la ayuda como las evacuaciones de
civiles al menos cuando puede no quieren
evacuar tienen miedo no quieren vivir en
estas condiciones
http como bajo las autoridades de donets
han estado continuamente a la población
a huir tras los bombardeos diarios desde
la caída de the lizzie chance en la
ciudad de bach mut sólo quedan cinco mil
habitantes muchos de los cuales son
ancianos y carecen de recursos para
marcharse ucrania está haciendo lo que
puede para evitar la invasión de rusia
sin embargo cualquier ayuda que venga de
más lejos puedes llegar demasiado tarde
para muchas partes de doñetsk
desde que rusia tomó el control de la
vecina lugar ha seguido presionando
hacia el oeste